[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers einen
guten Freitagabend ihnen allen es fehle
jetzt nur noch Gottes Wille das richtige
Wetter und die Entscheidung der
Kommandeure dann werde die Offensive der
Ukraine starten sagt deren
Verteidigungsminister heute und spricht
von den neu gelieferten Waffen aus dem
Westen als eiserner Faust manche
Beobachter rechnen mit der mehrfach
angekündigten Offensive jetzt bereits
nächste Woche und in der Tat
insbesondere die Unterstützer in den USA
erwarten Erfolge der Ukraine beim
Bemühen die russischen Angreifer
zurückzudrängen
heute erlebten die Menschen in der
Ukraine aber zunächst eine neue heftige
Welle von Raketenangriffen aus Russland
Christoph Wiesel berichtet
es ist früh am Morgen als die Raketen
einschlagen dieser Wohnblock in der
Stadt Oman südlich von Kiew wird voll
getroffen ein Video das in den sozialen
Netzwerken kursiert soll eine der
Wohnungen nach der Detonation zeigen
weinend filmt eine Frau die zerstörten
Zimmer hier haben unsere Kinder
geschlafen sagt sie die Bewohner die
können retten sich ins Freie eine
ältere Frau ihre Tochter und zwei Enkel
lebten im neunten Stock alle tot ein
Mann und sein Sohn im achten Stock auch
tot eine Mutter mit ihrer Tochter im
siebten Stock ebenfalls tot
insgesamt mindestens 23 Menschen werden
hier im Wohngebiet bei dem russischen
Angriff getötet Einsatzkräfte kämpfen
den ganzen Tag suchen nach den vielen
die immer noch vermisst werden
etwa zehn mehrstöckige Gebäude wurden
getroffen wir machen Tür zu türbesuche
gehen zu jeder Wohnung um
sicherzustellen dass es dort keine
weiteren verletzten oder toten gibt
human ist die Stadt die am heftigsten
von der Angriffswelle getroffen wird
scheinbar wahllos feuert Russland
Raketen ab auch in weitere Orte wie nie
pro und Kiew
in nepro sterben Behörden zufolge eine
Frau und ihr Kind die Raketen nach Kiew
werden nach ukrainischen Angaben
weitgehend abgefangen es ist das erste
Mal seit zwei Monaten das überhaupt
wieder Raketen in Richtung der
Hauptstadt fliegen der ukrainische
Präsident spricht von einer Nacht des
Terrors bei einem Treffen mit dem
Präsidenten Tschechien zählte eine
Schweigeminute ab und fordert weitere
Unterstützung des Westen
wir haben darüber gesprochen wie man ein
Land stoppen kann dass eine solche
Tragödie wie die heutige verursacht
einen terroristischen Staat und wie
waren alle russischen Terroristen und
Mörder zur Rechenschaft ziehen kann das
ist die wichtigste Aufgabe für alle in
Europa und in der freien Welt
[Musik]
in Oman hat die Stadtverwaltung eine
dreitägige Trauer angeordnet und den
Opfern des raketenangriffs zu gedenken
Christian Mölling ist bei uns
sicherheits- und verteidigungsexperte
bei der Deutschen Gesellschaft für
auswärtige Politik willkommen zurück im
heute-
militärischen Lage was bereitet denn die
Ukraine da offensichtlich vor und
welchen Erfolg kann das ganz konkret
haben
was sie genau vorbereitet das können wir
natürlich wissen sollten wir auch nicht
wissen würden wir wenn wir es wissen ja
auch nicht öffentlich diskutieren es
gibt das eine Szenario ganz grob dass
man versucht im Süden die besetzten
Gebiete soweit es geht zu befreien aber
zumindest die logistische Versorgung der
russischen Truppen zu unterbinden aber
wir wissen auch aus dem letzten Jahr das
Finden eigentliche gar kein schlechtes
Mittel sind um die Russen genau dort zu
treffen wo sich vielleicht am wenigsten
erwarten deswegen glaube ich sollte man
den Beginn der Offensive abwarten und
sehen Sie sich das dann letztendlich
entwickelt sie sagen wir sollten da
rüber eigentlich gar nicht so viel
wissen was aber doch auffällt ist dass
in der Ukraine selbst ziemlich viel
darüber geredet wird zuletzt heute vom
Verteidigungsminister welche Idee steckt
denn da dahinter ich glaube es geht
schon darum auf der einen Seite
die sagen die den Spannungsbogen
aufrecht zu halten und der die
schwierigen die schwierige Leistung die
auch der Verteidigungsminister in den
letzten Tagen versuchte es auf der einen
Seite zu sagen es geht los und auf der
anderen Seite aber die Erwartungen was
jetzt dieser offen die wir bringen kann
nicht in den Himmel schießen zu lassen
denn viele denken jetzt schon dass es
sozusagen die Endschlacht wäre die hier
jetzt kommen würde ich glaube das wäre
eine verfrühte Hoffnung die man da hätte
jetzt ist die Rede wenn wir mal so ein
paar Zahlen mit reinbringen manche sagen
30.000 neue Soldaten habe die Ukraine
aufgestellt 240 Panzer angenommen das
stimmt ordnen Sie das doch mal bitte ein
welche Größenordnung ist denn das ich
glaube
richtig ist schon dass Quantität eine
eigene Qualität ist aber wir haben ja
auch in den vergangenen Monaten gesehen
wie wichtig tatsächlich die Bereitschaft
ist zu kämpfen und sozusagen die Moral
der Soldaten deswegen würde ich bei den
Zahlen immer sagen na ja schauen wir mal
es hängt ja auch dann davon ab wo diese
Kräfte massiert werden und ob man den
richtigen Eintrittspunkt in die
russischen Verteidigungslinie kriegt
russland hat sicherlich gelernt aus der
aus den Niederlagen des letzten Jahres
und wird versuchen dieses mal schlauer
vorzugehen es wird die Frage sein findet
mal den Achtung in der russischen
Verteidigung um dann mit den nicht
wirklich wahnsinnig vielen Kampfpanzern
und Offensivwaffen die man hat
tatsächlich den entscheidenden Erfolg
nach vorne zu bringen das bringt mich
zur wichtigen Frage wie ist denn
Russland aufgestellt
naja russland hat wenn wir jetzt über
die Zahlen kommen würden deutlich mehr
Soldaten sicherlich zur Verfügung auf
der anderen Seite nicht so wahnsinnig
viele in der Ukraine aber alle diese
Leute sind wenn selbst wenn sie
einigermaßen gut ausgebildet worden sind
in den letzten Tagen Wochen Monaten
sicherlich wenig motiviert weil es
einfach nicht möglich ist den Leuten zu
erklären aufgrund der letzten Monate
noch diese Leute bekommen mir die
Nachrichten mit von dem was in bachmund
passiert das russische Soldaten rein
weil sie hier sterben und hören
Flugzeuge zahlt wird dass ihnen das
gleiche Schicksal droht und sie dagegen
eigentlich gar nichts machen können ihre
Entscheidung entweder sie sterben in den
Verteidigungslinien oder sie sterben
weil sie aufgrund des Widerstandes
erschossen werden dann reden bitte noch
ganz kurz um das über das ganz große
Bild wenn man so will die allergrößten
Unterstützer der Ukraine sitzen ja in
Washington dort scheint wenn man die
Presseberichte so verfolgt in der
letzten Zeit die Geduld langsam zu
schwinden die USA scheinen auch hinter
den Kulissen gegenüber Kiefer immer mehr
auf Erfolge zu drängen
geht da die Sorge um dass sich die
öffentliche Meinung wenden könnte
natürlich fängt der Wahlkampf an weil es
ist eigentlich schon länger so dass das
der Wahlkampf und die Republikaner
versuchen das Thema Ukraine zum
Wahlkampf Thema zu machen das hängt die
Handlungsoptionen des Präsidenten ein
wenn er denn tatsächlich noch mal
gewinnen will und damit auch die
Möglichkeit haben will die Ukraine
weiter zu unterstützen das ist also im
Grunde genommen wirklich ein Ritt auf
der Rasierklinge für ihn gleichzeitig
versuchen die Demokraten die
Republikaner mit an Bord zu holen für
die Unterstützung zur Ukraine und sagen
lasst uns doch dieses Thema gemeinsam
angehen du musst quasi zu entschärfen
für den Wahlkampf kann man also
zusammenfassend sagen die Ukraine ist
aus ganz vielen Gründen bei dieser
Offensive gerade zu zum Erfolg verdammt
ja das machen in der westlichen
Erwartungshaltung zu sein wir wissen
aber auch dass das Schlachtfeld eine
eigene Gesetzmäßigkeit hat also von
daher kann man eine hoffen dass es den
größtmöglichen Erfolg gibt aber wir
sollten auch nicht glauben dass das hier
die Endschlacht ist und das haben 2023
dieser Krieg vorbei ist Christian
Mölling herzlichen Dank auch heute Abend
wieder für ihre Expertise bei uns danke
schön ich danke ihnen sie was schönen
Abend danke Ihnen auch und dann gucken
wir jetzt natürlich auf die Menschen in
der Ukraine deren Alltag im Krieg den
wir nicht aus den Augen verlieren
sollten unsere Reporter daran ist im Bus
unterwegs der einzigen Verbindung für
die Zivilbevölkerung in eine Stadt an
der Südfront
orichif die Front ist nur 5 km entfernt
täglicher Beschuss seit nun über einem
Jahr auf die Straße geht nur wer muss
die Menschen leben in Kellern es gibt
neuen solcher öffentlicher Bunker in der
Stadt
Olga und ihr Minibus halten die
Verbindung in die Stadt aufrecht zweimal
am Tag fährt sie die Strecke von
saporisha und zurück und 50 km liegen
zwischen den Städten
gefährlich ist es hier immer sie
beschießen die Strecke häufig du weißt
nie wann und wo es einschlagen wird und
die Stadt ulriche wird quasi 24 Stunden
beschossen
zwei Euro kostet die Fahrt Kilometer für
Kilometer nähert sich der Minibus dem
Krieg wer eingestiegen ist hat einen
gewichtigen Grund
mein Bruder wurde von einer Bombe
getötet ich weiß immer noch keine
Einzelheiten ich komme nach Hause zurück
weil meine Mutter noch dort ist
wir erreichen nur richtig Olga zeigt uns
die Einschläge sie sei immer wieder
überrascht wie schnell die Bürger die
Straßen von Splittern beseitigen sagt
sie extra Halt für olexandra sein
schwerer Gang nach Hause zur Mutter soll
wenigstens kurz sein
und setzt sie an der Schule ab jetzt ein
öffentlicher Bunker er bietet Schutz für
rund 150 Menschen Strom und
Wasserversorgung sind autark in der Zeit
in der wir da sind gab es zwei
Artillerie Einschläge außerhalb der
Stadt
wir hoffen dass die gegen Offensive sehr
bald beginnt und dass es ein Erfolg wird
wir hoffen dass der Feind vertrieben
wird weit weg von uns damit sie uns
nicht mehr treffen können
Busfahrerin olga hat draußen gewartet 40
Minuten Standzeit sieht der Fahrplan vor
und daran hält sie sich auch im Krieg
ich mochte diese Stadt ziemlich gerne
aber jetzt existiert sie kaum noch
und Angst die habe ich nicht mehr seit
den ersten Einschlägen in saporisha es
waren so viele
ich bin ruhig keine Panik keine Furcht
die Rückfahrt wieder vorbei an Ruinen
ihr Talent sei es ruhig zu bleiben sagt
Olga und verliert kein Wort darüber dass
sie heute umsonst auf Fahrgäste gewartet
hat
eine Busfahrerin und der Krieg so viel
zur Lage in der Ukraine für heute Abend
hier bei uns in diesem Land geht wenig
schnell das Wissen dessen Bürgerinnen
und Bürger schon länger das hat aber
auch die Regierung erkannt und spricht
seitdem vom neuen deutschlandtempo damit
sollen marode Verkehrswege aus und
umgebaut werden und zwar nicht so wie
aktuell an vielen Baustellen zu sehen wo
das eigentlich geplante
Fertigstellungsdatum auf den Schildern
immer neu über pinselt werden muss immer
weiter Richtung St nimmerlandstag
sondern eben schnell der
Bundesverkehrsminister will auch eine
ganze Reihe von Autobahnen beschleunigt
ausbauen droht dabei jetzt allerdings
von manchen Ländern ausgebremst zu
werden das ganze sieht aus wie eine neue
Folge im Grundsatzstreit FDP gegen grüne
Heiko Rams
noch läuft der Verkehr wenn auch
einspurig auf der habachtalbrücke bei
Aachen die a544 ist die zentrale
Anbindung der Stadt ans Autobahnnetz
doch bald wird die marode Brücke und
damit die Autobahn voll gesperrt es
droht ein Verkehrschaos in der Stadt
Aachen und in der Städteregion ist
wirklich im Moment Alarmstimmung
Alarmstimmung weil man befürchtet dass
der Verkehr rund um die Stadt und das
ist das Oberzentrum kollabiert die
potenziellen Schäden die wir haben sind
die das Unternehmen diesen Standort
verlassen oder ganz aufgeben
viele Autobahnbrücken in Deutschland
sind in einem schlechten Zustand in den
nächsten zehn Jahren müssen allein in
NRW 873 Brücken saniert werden so dass
NRW Verkehrsministerium
Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing dagegen
will Engstellen auf Autobahnen
beseitigen dafür sollen 145
autobahnprojekte in Deutschland
beschleunigt angegangen werden fast die
Hälfte davon in Nordrhein-Westfalen wie
das Autobahnkreuz Kaiserberg in Duisburg
der Bund braucht dafür die Zustimmung
der Länder doch für NRW Verkehrsminister
Krischer mangelt es an Informationen in
einem Brief an den
Bundesverkehrsminister der dem ZDF
vorliegt heißt es Zitat
wie lauten die aktuellen Planungsstände
der anstehenden Vorhaben und wie sieht
der konkrete Plan des Bundes zur
Umsetzung der Sanierung von
Autobahnbrücken in Nordrhein-Westfalen
aus
für eine Entscheidung seien diese
Informationen essentiell schreibt der
Minister
was nützt mir ein Autobahnausbau den ich
in ein paar Jahren habe wenn die
zehnspurige oder achtspurige Autobahn
dann vor einer kaputten Brücke endet und
das muss miteinander sinnvoll in
Zusammenhang gebracht werden
vorerst also keine Zustimmung aus NRW
für die Berliner Pläne so wie er auch
aus anderen Ländern bei denen die Grünen
mit an der Regierung sind für den
Sprecher des
Bundesverkehrsministeriums heute Mittag
ist das kein Problem die Rückmeldung
dafür ist heute zu geben
es würde im Endeffekt bedeuten dass die
Projekte die nicht zurückgemeldet werden
dann eben nach den bisherigen Verfahren
umgesetzt werden
Verkehrsexperten halten die Pläne des
Bundesverkehrsministeriums für einen
Fehler
wir haben in Deutschland nicht die
Möglichkeit alles auf einmal zu machen
Ausbaumaßnahmen und Sanierung das heißt
wir müssen alle Kräfte in die Sanierung
stecken wenn die Sanierungsmaßnahmen zu
spät erfolgen ist ganz klar dann kann
man nun Sperrung arbeiten und das heißt
wir werden mehrere Brückenbauwerke haben
dann die nicht mehr befahrbar sind und
das für viele Jahre so wie in
Lüdenscheid die marode Rahmen der
Talbrücke ist bereits gesperrt und soll
ihn gut einer Woche gesprengt werden
weitere wichtige Nachrichten hast du
jetzt im Blick Hannah in der Übersicht
ja da schauen wir zuerst auf eine
Entscheidung des Bundestags dieser hat
heute grünes Licht für den
Bundeswehreinsatz in Niger gegeben bis
zu 60 Soldatinnen und Soldaten können
nun entsendet werden und die EU-Mission
in dem westafrikanischen Land
unterstützen ziel ist die Stabilisierung
des Landes so geht es unter anderem um
die Ausbildung des niedrigen Militärs im
Kampf gegen islamistische Terrorgruppen
nach dem Ende des
evakuierungseinsatzes im Sudan sind rund
400 Beteiligte Soldatinnen und Soldaten
der Bundeswehr nach Deutschland
zurückgekehrt auf dem Fliegerhorst in
Wunstorf landeten am Nachmittag vier
Maschinen der Luftwaffe
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius und
Außenministerin baerbock nahm die Truppe
in Empfang und danken ihr für den
Einsatz die Bundeswehr hat mehr als 700
Menschen aus dem umkämpften Sudan
ausgeflogen
und später im heute journal Update gibt
es dann ein Gespräch dazu mit dem
General major Dirk Faust dem Mann der
die Bundeswehr Rettungsaktion
verantwortet hat
die eu-finanzministerinnen und Minister
diskutieren aktuell in Stockholm über
die Reform der EU Schuldenregeln und
eine Einigung scheint vorerst nicht in
Sicht
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner forderte
Nachbesserungen Vorschläge der
Kommission sein nur ein erster Schritt
es brauche in Zahlen gegossene Vorgaben
beim Abbau die EU-Kommission will
dagegen künftig individuelle Regeln für
die Rückzahlung der Schulden mit den
einzelnen Staaten vereinbaren
nach den beiden Messerattacken in
Duisburg hat nun der Generalbundesanwalt
die Ermittlungen übernommen sowohl bei
der Tat in einem Fitnessstudio als auch
bei dem tödlichen Angriff auf einen
35-Jährigen am Osterwochenende gebe es
Anhaltspunkte für ein islamistisches
Motiv erklärte eine Sprecherin ein
26-jähriger Syrer wird verdächtigt beide
Taten begangen zu haben er sitzt in
Untersuchungshaft
wenn es in der Diskussion darum geht was
alles gar nicht so schlecht war an der
DDR dann kommt recht schnell und recht
häufig die Kinderbetreuung es gab
flächendeckend Krippen Vereinbarkeit von
Beruf und Familie leichter gemacht es
gab allerdings auch etwas anderes ganz
spezielles und darum geht es jetzt in
einer Ausstellung in Rostock die große
Diskussionen auslöst sogenannte Wochen
Krippen wo Mütter ihre Kinder wenige
Wochen nach der Geburt abgeben konnten
und dann nur am Wochenende zu sich nach
Hause holten um auch im Schichtdienst
arbeiten zu können die Folgen spüren
manche Familien bis heute Susanne Seidel
schmerzhafte Erinnerungen sie schweben
über dem Herzstück der Ausstellung einem
Gitterbettchen sie erzählen von
Einsamkeit und Schmerz
Kornelia gloga auch sie war als Baby
unter der Woche rund um die Uhr in der
wochenkrippe und leitet bis heute
darunter trotz der nur schemenhaften
Erinnerungen diese Gitterstäbe die sind
schon Teil der Persönlichkeit so und
immer noch die sind vielleicht jetzt
nicht mehr so da und aber die sind in
den Zellen die eingeschrieben aber auch
Selbstvorwürfe und Rechtfertigungen der
Eltern beherrschen den Raum glogas
Mutter Brigitte musste damals eine
Dreiviertelstunde zur Arbeit fahren und
entschied sich deswegen gegen eine
normale tagesgrippe für ihren Säugling
dann hätte ich um 5 Uhr mein Kind aus
dem Schlaf holen müssen und abends nach
Hause um 19 Uhr essen gehen ist ein
bisschen Vorlesen spielen ins Bett und
da habe ich entschieden für mich das
kannst du deinem Kind nicht zumuten dein
Baby
Cornelia Gloger ist 210 ehemaligen
Wochen Krippenkindern die Teil der
Ausstellung sind sie erzählen in
Collagen und Interviews dass sie sich
durch die ständige Trennung von der
Familie einsam und bis heute nicht
zugehörig fühlten auch so viel Linz die
selbst in einer wochengrippe war und die
Ausstellung konzipierte ich bekomme
Zuschriften von vielen vielen
Betroffenen die auch jetzt noch
mitmachen wollen bei dem Projekt und die
sagen sie fühlen sich das erste Mal hier
auch verstanden und auch hat abgeholt
1966 lebten knapp 40.000 Säuglinge und
Kleinkinder in Wochen Krippen die gab es
nach dem Krieg auch in Westdeutschland
wo sie jedoch wieder verschwanden als
die schädlichen Folgen für das
Bindungsverhalten der Kinder bekannt
wurde in der DDR galten sie weiterhin
als Errungenschaft als Unterstützung für
die arbeitenden Mütter die in der
Industrie dringend gebraucht worden
Psychologin Eva Flemming leitet derzeit
an der unimedizin Rostock eine Studie
über ehemalige Wochen Krippenkinder die
meisten ihrer Probanden berichten von
bindungsproblemen bis heute viele
beschreiben dann ein lebenslangen auch
schwieriges Verhältnis insbesondere zu
den Müttern also meistens ein sehr
ambivalentes Verhältnis
und viele nennen auch spontan erstmal so
ein fehlendes Urvertrauen nur wenige
Mütter und Kinder sprechen so offen wie
die glogas über die Zeit in der
wochengrippe
oder meine Mutter oder mein Vater
anzuklagen sondern einfach auch zu
zeigen dass man so nicht mit Kindern
umgeht man sperrt die nicht in ein
Gitterbett so lieb wie die alle gemeint
haben das tut man nicht Es ist ein
heikles für viele sogar ein
schmerzhaftes Thema das die Kunsthalle
Rostock aufgegriffen hat
konnte ich natürlich nicht da sein aber
sie haben sich Mühe gegeben auf jeden
Fall die Aufarbeitung dieser Zeit hat
gerade erst lernen
und jetzt geht es weiter mit dir Hanau
mit Schloss ganz anderem
Inflation in Deutschland hat sich ein
weiteres Mal etwas abgeschwächt bleibt
allerdings mit 7,2% auf hohem Niveau und
großer Preistreiber sind mittlerweile
die Lebensmittel das wollen wir genauer
einordnen Frank Bethmann wie ist das zu
erklären allein damit dass die Landwirte
für ihre Erzeugnisse mehr verlangt haben
jedenfalls nicht mehr besonders bei
Gurken oder Tomaten beispielsweise ist
der Preisdruck nicht mehr da ungeachtet
dessen auf Jahres Sicht verteuerten sich
Nahrungsmittel im April um über 17
Prozent bei Zucker Milch oder Käse ist
noch immer kein Ende abzusehen manche
Preissteigerungen sagen
Verbraucherschützer sein inzwischen
weder gerechtfertigt noch
nachvollziehbar nutzt die
Lebensmittelbranche also die Lage aus
die letzten Geschäftszahlen von
Lebensmittel riesen wieder ohne oder
Nestlé z.B lassen diesen Rückschluss
vermuten und zumindest ein Teil der
jüngsten Preissteigerung sei auch auf
die Marktmacht des Handel zurückzuführen
sagen Branchenkenner
und dann gab es noch eine weitere
wichtige Meldung heute die deutsche
Wirtschaft ist Anfang des Jahres knapp
an einer Rezession vorbeigeschlettert ja
das stimmt sie ist wieder geschrumpft
noch hat sie zugelegt gleichwohl bleibt
der Ausblick schwierig jeder sagt was
anderes die Bundesregierung rechnet aus
ja gesehen mit einem kleinen Wachstum
der IWF prognostiziert dagegen eher
einen leichten Rückgang der deutschen
Wirtschaftsleistung der DAX springt vor
diesem Hintergrund vielleicht etwas
überraschend auf ein neues Jahres hoch
geht mit
15.922 Punkten ins Wochenende und nimmt
die Probleme mit gegenwärtig stagniert
die deutsche Wirtschaft also er als dass
sie Vorankommen kommt vielen Dank Frank
für diese Einschätzung
ja und die schwache konjunkturelle
Entwicklung hat auch Auswirkungen auf
den Arbeitsmarkt die frühjahrsbelegung
belebt Belebung kommt kaum in Schwung im
April waren laut Bundesagentur für
Arbeit zwei Millionen
zwei Millionen 586.000 Menschen ohne Job
das sind rund 8000 weniger als im März
die Arbeitslosenquote liegt unverändert
bei 5,7% im Vergleich zum Vorjahr sind
276.000 Menschen mehr arbeitslos
während der corona-pandemie hatte der
Bund den Reisekonzern TUI mit
Staatshilfen von insgesamt 4,3
Milliarden Euro vor der Pleite bewahrt
heute hatte das Unternehmen seine
verbliebenen Schulden zurückgezahlt mit
einer letzten Überweisung von 750
Millionen Euro darin enthalten sind auch
Zinsen und andere Abgaben durch die
Rettungsaktion des Touristikkonzerns hat
der Staat unterm Strich mehrere hundert
Millionen Euro Gewinn gemacht
heute vor 100 Jahren das war ein schöner
Frühlingstag in London die U-Bahn
meldete rekordverkauf von Tickets für
die Fahrt nach Wembley wo ein neues
Stadion eingeweiht werden sollte mit
Platz für
127.000 Zuschauer am Ende waren 300.000
da der heilige Rasen sah so aus voller
Menschen die Spieler der beiden
Mannschaften im englischen Pokalfinale
hatten schon den letzten Weg zu Fuß
gehen müssen weil ihr Bus im Getümmel
stecken geblieben war jetzt warteten sie
in den Kabinen bis die Polizei
wenigstens das Spielfeld frei bekommt
direkt dahinter stehen die Zuschauer
dicht und können kaum etwas erkennen
so entstehen Legenden Orte die zum
Mythos werden eine Kathedrale des
Fußballs wird heute 100 Andreas Stamm
aus Wembley
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist mehr als nur irgendein Stadion
Wembley der Ort an dem großes passiert
über den Fußball hinaus
doch es sind die Tore oder nicht Tore
aus den englischen lagerfeuergeschichten
wurden
und Geschichte selbst
[Applaus]
an die Ex-Nationalspieler die leider
verstorben sind sie wurden betrauert wie
Kriegshelden von Menschen die viel zu
jung sind um sie zu kennen oder sie je
auf dem Spielfeld erlebt zu haben
schon die Premiere in Wembley vor genau
100 Jahren elektrisiert die Massen das
Stadion wird gestürmt das Pokalfinale
zwischen West Ham und Bolten kann erst
beginnen nachdem ein einsamer Polizist
auf dem Schimmel Billy die bis zu
300.000 Zuschauer unter Kontrolle bringt
ein erstes Wunder erklärt
kommentatorenlegende
ist es nicht weit man kommt von Wembley
und beginnt an Deutschland zu denken ich
hatte das große Glück dass Champions
League Finale 2013 zu kommentieren was
für die Fans von Bayern und Dortmund
unglaublich bedeutend war ein ikonisches
Aufeinandertreffen an einem ikonischen
Ort aber ich bin gerade alt genug um
mich an den Anfang der Rivalität zu
erinnern an 1966
das Tor über das Menschen seit
Jahrzehnten streiten das laut
Computerberechnungen keines war
Weltmeister 66 der Höhepunkt des
englischen Fußballs danach die Rache für
und in Wembley em72 Deutschland siegt im
Viertelfinale noch schmerzhafter
EM-Halbfinale 96 11 Meter Schießen
wieder lacht das DFB-Team bis zum
Endpunkt der englischen Tragödie dem
letzten Spiel vor dem Abriss des alten
Stadions Dietmar Hamann zum 1:0 entstand
im Oktober 2000 bis heute sitzt der
Schmerz tief und verhindert das Hamann
im neuen Stadion ein Denkmal gesetzt
wurde es wurde dann aber doch noch ein
Pferd benannt dass größeres über
verhindert hat deswegen ist es jetzt die
White House Bridge und der Engländer
sind ja sehr faire Sportsmänner aber
dann eine Brücke am Wembley Stadion nach
dem deutschen zu benennen soweit geht
die die Ferne ist oder die Freundschaft
dann doch nicht
über das Flair des neuen Stadions
streiten sich die Gelehrten doch
Geschichte lässt sich nicht aufhalten
Elfmeterschießen EM-Finale 21 England
weint mal nicht gegen Deutschland und
lacht als die Damen es ebenfalls im
Finale der EM ein Jahr später besser
machen diesmal wieder gegen den
Erzrivalen was folgt gab es noch in
keinem Stadion Wembley eben der die
pilles nannte Kathedrale des Fußballs
seiner Hauptstadt und dessen Herz
es gibt quasi nichts was Wembley nicht
erlebt hat 1961 haben sie dort ein
Skispringen ausgetragen auf Kunstschnee
im Juni Sieger wurde
falkoin aus Finnland
dazu passend nach uns die heute-show und
gegen 0 Uhr begrüßt Sie an dieser Stelle
wohl schmiese mit unserem heute
journal-update von uns allen hier im
Team ein angenehmer Abend tschüss
[Musik]
einen wunderschönen guten Abend zum
Wetter ja das kleine tief was du hier
das hat uns heute noch mal einiges an
Regen gebracht und der April 2023 war
auch der nasseste april in Deutschland
seit 15 Jahren das hat zur Folge dass
ich die Bodenfeuchte wieder gut erholt
hat das Wochenende jetzt allerdings das
wird ein trockenes werden denn tief
Vasco zieht heute Nacht und morgen nach
Osten hin ab und dann folgt ein kleines
zwischen hoch das heißt rickster das
löst die Wolken dann so langsam auf
heute Nacht allerdings noch nicht da
verlagert sich der Regen dann erstmal
ostwärts die kräftigen Gewitter im
Südwesten und der Dauerregen am
Alpenrand lassen im Verlauf der Nacht
dann aber nach wo es aufklärt kann sich
auch mal Nebel bilden die Temperaturen
im Nordosten des Landes sind nicht mehr
so kühl wie in der vergangene Nacht
haben wir sechs Grad im Süden sind das
auch mal zehn elf Grad heute Nacht
morgen gibt es viele Wolken über der
Mitte auch aus denen ist dann auch immer
mal ein bisschen Regen geben kann
inklusive Schauer an den Alpen im Süden
und auch im Norden da gibt es allerdings
auch viel Sonne an der Nordsee sind
Sonnenstunden von bis zu zwölf Stunden
drin im Süden sind das immerhin fünf bis
acht Stunden Sonne morgen dazwischen ist
es allerdings trüber mit 0 bis 2 Stunden
Sonne die Temperaturen sind ganz
unterschiedlich 11 Grad gibt es an der
Nordsee südlich der Donau und am
Oberrhein 20-21 Grad und das ist auch
die Temperaturspanne der nächsten Tage
am Sonntag gibt es trockenes
Ausflugswetter mit viel Sonne im Norden
ein paar mehr Wolken im Süden am Montag
wird es im Süden allerdings etwas
wechselhaft damit auch kräftigeren
Gewittern alles in allem ist es aber ein
freundliches langes Wochenende hier
wünsche ich Ihnen jetzt noch einen
schönen Abend tschüss